hey my name is Maria and um I'm
originally from Duluth Minnesota Duluth
and Hassell yeah my um my mother told me
before I went to my first girl boy party
in the 8th grade she said Maria remember
what we talked about gonorrhea syphilis
herpes one to watch the cold sores date
rape is a lot more common than people
think you look so gorgeous you were
conceived in Groton Connecticut in one
night in a campsite I am NOT saying you
weren't planned I'm just saying
Bamford's get pregnant like falling off
logs Oh Jen he's not here to pick you up
while the other good time she's kind of
religious though so she gets all mad at
me because I don't know if I believe in
God because I don't like the idea of
some touched by an angel angels sitting
up there making decisions like I'm gonna
put you in a paralyzing diving accident
so you can inspire people with
watercolors you paint with your feet I'm
gonna kill your mother so that you're
more friendly at work I'm going to put
you through a really crappy childhood so
then when you're 42 and you've been
through drug and alcohol rehab you can
give experience strengthen hope
does someone else who's been through a
really crappy childhood but I put them
in
I've been thinking about getting breast
implants because I'm a radical militant
feminist and I'm I was trying to
rationalize it by saying it's just like
the jungle tribes woman who says to the
National Geographic translator I know
they're going to be physical
implications if I insert a nine and a
half inch diameter clay lip plate into
my mouth but I'm doing this for me and
it also represents how many cattle my
husband receives at the time of our
engagement I used to work as a secretary
and it was really creepy creepy boss and
he would always come with me and stuff
say stuff like I really like when you
wear your hair don't like that he's got
a picture of your boyfriend well if I
were still his a Jeff give a run for his
money well why don't you come in the
meeting and take shorthand cheer up the
guys with your pretty face come on smile
for me it looks so much more beautiful
when you smile like that go in his
office and say stuff like hi I really
love the way your gray curly neck hair
comes up of the edge of your peach poly
weave sweat stain sports shirt oh don't
make me jealous with those pictures of
your fat angry why
why don't you come in my cubicle and
tell me more about my partial dental
benefits after 90 days come on smile for
me the fact that I net six dollars and
49 cents an hour to provide you with a
sexual stimulation you're not man enough
to get in your personal life is so much
more apparent when you smile and I'm I
decided the worst the job is the more
excited the temporary representative is
about it
hello Maria this is Judy from TRC
staffing in Glendale
good morning I have an incredible
opportunity here for you today five
dollars an hour alphanumerical in an
industrial warehouse I thought of you
first
I kept expect to get to get worse hello
Marie this is a 2d tijuana mexico
loading fruit trucks you need to be
there in a half-hour
corporate dress hello Maria this is it I
have a feeling temperature perm Thailand
you are sold into prostitution but there
is free parking
thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Applause]